how many times did Daniel Radcliffe  break his  wand this is a rumor I would like to  disperse there is a thing that I  sometimes see on Twitter that's like  when I'm going on it to not have one but  look at other people's amazing fact or  weird trivia thing will pop up and it'll  be like down directive broke a hundred  ones or like 60 ones on set it's not  that many guys I used to like uh use  them in like a drum on my leg with it  the whole time and like be doing that  all the time and eventually you know you  sort of wear them down and and they will  break but yeah it wasn't it wasn't as  many as that I feel like everyone got  through a few and I was probably 12. Max  I'm an absolute maximum of 20.